LOUIS GRAY: Welcome to the
first edition of Google
Developers Weekly, our highlight
reel of what's
happening in the world
of Google Developers
on the set and off.
I'm Louis Gray from the Google
Developers Live team.
Every month, we broadcast dozens
of shows from Google
Developer studios all around
the world covering the
products and APIs that
you care about most.
Our engineers show you the
latest news, tips, and how
to's to make your code great.
But you're busy, so we
created this show.
Each week, we're going to take
a few minutes to run through
some of the Google Developers
highlights.
So let's get started.
First, early last week from
Berlin, Martin Gorner sat down
with SoundCloud to talk about
reactive programming, a new
design pattern that helps you
build responsive UIs.
From Milan, Italy, Marco Casario
developed Part Three
of his Responsive Web Design
series focusing on using CSS
to load resources depending on
what type of browser or device
you're using.
From Tel Aviv, the GDL Israel
team did a deep dive into the
wow and the how of web RTC.
Back here in Mountain View, we
saw many different product
teams take their turns behind
the desk to enlighten us on
what's new.
The Google Drive team
instructed us on how
collaborator email addresses are
handled for those of you
who may have started with the
Documents List API and noticed
how the move to Drive
changed permissions.
Until this show aired,
I had no idea.
It's a good thing Steve Basil
was there to help us out and
help me finally get it.
We even let the interns
into the studio.
In what some might argue is
the pinnacle of his career
stay here at the Googleplex,
intern Sam Stern showed us how
to build Google+ sign in and
add it to applications that
already integrate with
other social
networks, such as Facebook.
Thanks for dropping by Sam.
Now that you've left us, don't
forget to show up on time for
class when the bell rings.
Since every single one of our
Google Developers Live events
shows up on YouTube, having the
YouTube Developers Live
team show up in our
studio seems one
step short of inception.
We must go deeper.
And yet the team shows up
practically every Wednesday,
including the most recent week
with guest Storyful, who calls
himself the news agency of the
social media age and is
focused on social media
verification.
Very cool stuff.
Want to know when your studio
has been invaded by Canadians?
Look for the tin foil hats.
Vancouver resident Tim Bray,
alongside Googler Adam Dawes
brought his tin foil hat into
the studio and railed on for
some time about identity
providers, federation, and who
you can trust these days.
You won't want to miss it.
We finally wrapped the week with
a demo that required a 65
inch, 110-pound television set
to be precariously balanced in
our studio, violating at least
nine workplace safety rules.
The reason--
Google Wallet is going web and
mortar, linking online
commerce to the real world.
We'd be remiss if we didn't give
a big head nod and tip of
the cap to our Android
Developers Live team, who in
their own right are consistently
teaching us how
to make programs beautiful,
taking applications to the
clinic for deep inspection, and
dropping dead bytes on the
Android Developers
YouTube channel.
Don't miss that if you're
a developer
thinking about mobile.
And let's be honest, right now,
MobileFirst is the new black.
Meanwhile, outside of our
studios for the rare times we
leave here, on our Google
Developers blog and Google+
page, we actually had a few more
announcements last week
in the world of Google
Developers.
First, the Chrome Web Lab
finished its run in London,
but the good news is the program
is being open sourced
and will live on forever.
Forever is a long time.
Meanwhile, Google's security
team continues to be in a
giving mood in now announcing
that they've given out $2
million to the Developer
community in security rewards.
Because each installation of
Chrome is free, that comes out
to about infinity dollars
per copy.
To make sure you never miss a
thing from the world of Google
Developers, subscribe to Google
Developers on YouTube
and check out our GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you in the studio.